[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: Let's
have a look at the API
runtime in Apigee Edge.
You have services or
you're developing services.
The goal is to expose
them as consumable APIs
with the appropriate security
and behavior and management.
Let me show you just
some of the options
in Apigee Edge that
help with that.
First, let's talk
about API security.
We'll start with a bare API.
This is a JSON API, and
there's no security implemented
by the back-end system.
With Apigee Edge,
you can add security
without changing
that back-end system.
The simplest and easiest way
to apply security to an API
is with API key verification.
Let me show you.
I create an API proxy,
specifying the back-end URL
as the target.
I add in key verification with
the Verify API Key policy.
Save that.
And now, every inbound request
will need to pass and API key.
Easy.
By the way, to
make this feasible,
obviously, we need clients
to invoke the proxy,
not the existing
back-end system.
And we need to restrict
access to that back-end system
so that only the Apigee Edge
proxy can connect with it.
We normally do this with a
two-way TLS on that connection.
As a more advanced
alternative, Apigee Edge
supports OAuth version 2.0.
This allows you to verify
a token within the API
proxy rather than a key.
A token is a time-limited key
derived from the consumer key.
Virtually every
Apigee customer uses
OAuth to secure their APIs.
Token verification works very
similarly to key verification.
It's a single
policy in the proxy.
Save it.
And now, every inbound request
must present a valid token.
Apigee Edge can, of
course, issue tokens
according to the various
OAuth 2.0 grants--
client credentials,
authorization code,
implicit password.
And you can specify the expiry
of tokens, the scope on tokens,
when you issue them.
Now, let's talk
about API beauty.
We know that beauty is in
the eye of the beholder.
But let me tell you,
today's developers
don't want to
behold XML or SOAP.
Your older services
might work great,
but if they're not
easy to consume,
you won't get the
agility you want.
With Apigee Edge, you can
transform those older services
into elegant, easy-to-use APIs.
First, let me show
you a SOAP service.
The response includes lots of
angle brackets, namespaces,
and framing.
Not beautiful.
This is what we see
with legacy services
and some third-party SaaS
services you might depend on.
An Apigee Edge proxy can accept
a simpler inbound payload
and transform that
into the heavier XML
the existing service expects.
And at the same time, it
can transform the response
into lighter weight XML.
An easy way to do
this is with XSLT.
For the request
and the response,
I just include an XSL
policy in the API proxy
and specify the transform.
Let's see it work.
Wow, much simpler.
Taking that a step
further, Apigee
can transform the
simpler XML into JSON.
We use the built-in XML
to JSON policy for that.
Here's what it looks like.
I'll invoke it again.
So easy.
No more angle brackets.
What if I want to transform
the resulting JSON?
Maybe I want to
rename the properties
or augment that payload with
some additional client-specific
data.
I can do that with
a JavaScript policy.
This is really neat.
Within the API proxy, I can
add a little bit of script
that manipulates the
payload in any way I'd like.
Super easy, simple,
and it works great.
By composing
multiple policies, I
can have the proxy
perform the transformation
that I want for any API.
Existing services get renewed.
That's an API makeover.
We talked about
security and beauty.
Let's talk about
performance now.
Some back-end services
are expensive.
Maybe it's a third-party service
where you pay by the call
or where you've
got a call limit,
or maybe it's a large data
set that changes slowly,
like a product catalog, and
it's just not worth reassembling
that result each time.
You can use Apigee Edge
caching to cache the results
of back-end services.
This can deliver noticeable
performance gains
for clients and users
and can relieve pressure
on back-end systems.
Just one additional policy.
Here, I'll show you the
difference in performance
using the Apigee Edge cache.
The uncached service takes
hundreds of milliseconds.
The cached service
takes less than 10.
At scale, that makes
a huge difference.
And with Apigee Edge,
you have fine control
over the cache expiry
and granularity.
OK, I've showed you how to
make a back-end service more
consumable by adding
security and beautifying it.
Another common desire
is to be able to compose
multiple back-end systems
into a single API.
Maybe you want to
add a geocoding API.
Maybe you want to add in
a data protection API.
So composition is a thing.
With Apigee Edge,
you can do that.
The service callout
policy is a simple way
to gather a response
that can then
be composed with the
response from the back end.
I just drop in a
policy, configure it,
and then I can
combine that response
with the response
from the target.
Suppose you've got
multiple systems
and you want some light
orchestration, maybe
coordinated with
conditional logic.
With Apigee Edge, you
can use the hosted target
to do that orchestration.
Write your logic in
Node.js or Python or Java.
The inbound request is
proxied to your code.
And that code can then
decide what back end or back
ends to invoke.
It all runs within the scope
of the Apigee API proxy.
Finally, Apigee Edge includes
extensions, so you can easily
connect into existing services,
like Google BigQuery, Cloud
functions or storage, or AWS
Lambda, or the Informatica
Cloud.
The extension capability
is available right
from the policy palette.
Just drop in an extension,
and it will execute
within the proxy context.
You can combine any or
all of these techniques
in a single API proxy to compose
your APIs the way you'd like.
Now, I want to show you
how you can use Apigee
Edge for conditional routing.
In the simple case,
Apigee Edge gives you
circuit breaker capability.
Apigee can automatically
distribute load
across a set of
back-end services
while monitoring the
health of those services
and removing unhealthy
points from rotation.
But suppose you want to
perform some conditional
routing, maybe routing based
on a varying weight for A/B
testing or canary
rollouts or maybe routing
based on a client ID.
Apigee Edge allows
you to do that, too.
Here, I built a
dynamic router based
on a routing table lookup
and some JavaScript
to select the target.
When I want to add in a new
target or change the weights,
I just update the table.
No need to touch the
API proxy, and we've
got data-driven routing.
And again, you can
compose this capability
with the other
elements you've seen,
for example, conditionally
executing an extension callout.
Here, I showed you some
of the basic capabilities
of Apigee Edge--
adding security to existing
APIs, beautifying existing
APIs, composition,
extensions, caching, routing.
This is just the start.
There's much more
capability in the product--
role-based access control,
mandatory flows for APIs,
IP whitelisting,
header injection.
Apigee Edge is a power
tool for curating
beautiful, secure,
consumable APIs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]